with conflicting polls out there House
Republican leaders and their major
supporters are not taking any chances
ahead of November's midterm elections
Sheldon Adelson has given thirty million
dollars to help the House GOP keep its
majority and House Democratic Leader
Nancy Pelosi may have given Republicans
another gift by suggesting she'd
increased taxes well the second part
there is accurate I do think that we
should revisit a tax legislation in the
way that we always have in a bipartisan
transparent way that the result is
unifying for the country Republican
campaign operatives say they plan to
play that clip until Election Day in
November and suggests it might be the
shot in the arm needed to energize the
GOP base is that enough to alarm
Republican voters across the country
they want to raise taxes and hardworking
Americans they want to raise taxes on
businesses they want to make it harder
for American businesses to stay in
America I can't imagine that America
will want that to happen
House Republican whip Steve Scalise says
his members can run on their record last
thing people want to do is turn the
clock back and go back to when Pelosi
was speaker and they raised taxes they
rammed through a lot of legislation that
wrecked the economy the chair of the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee told Fox his side is ready for
a battle I'll stand by our candidates
I'll stand by our polling I never said
this would be easy we're gonna have to
fight for every inch and I just know
that we're gonna be in a position to do
so as part of trying to win their races
some Democrats are calling for new
leadership and say they won't support
Pelosi she is downplaying it for now say
she's just focused on winning back the
house